[Music]
new Bordeaux a modern city with
traditional southern values
underestimated how high it was gonna go
what he was willing to do visit the
historic French Ward and enjoy local
cuisine at one of our five-star
restaurant killing them wasn't enough
linking clay was using them to send a
message or spend the afternoon in Hawaii
and take in its natural splendor Sal
marcano have no idea what he was going
to unleash Ubaldo Singh family all
headed for make it your next vacation
destination this is the city survived
for war of 1812 the Civil War and God
knows how many hurricanes but when
Lincoln clay went after the mob he
inflicted more damage than all the wars
and hurricanes combined
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Hayden Blackman
creative director and studio head at
hangar 13 but I wanted to thank you for
coming out to see our Gamescom
presentation of mafia 3 an open-world
crime drama set in new Bordeaux our
version of New Orleans in 1968 one of
the most tumultuous years in American
history in mafia 3 you'll play as
Lincoln clay an orphan and Vietnam vet
who falls in with new Bordeaux's black
Maw when the black mob is betrayed and
slaughtered by the Italian mob led by a
guy named Sal mark tano Lincoln becomes
fixated on revenge
as Lincoln you'll wage a brutal war
against the Italians disrupting the
balance of power and new Bordeaux's
underworld
today we're going to jump straight into
the middle of Lincoln's war with the mob
and his attempts to build and maintain
his new criminal family we're going to
start in the bayou and head for the
French war
[Music]
what would I give just to have you here
sailmaker will try to slip away somehow
[Music]
Oh need you darling
I want to see you around
[Music]
yes in mafia 3 we treat new Bordeaux as
a main character we've not only worked
hard to capture a unique time in place
but also to ensure that everything the
player does in the open world propels
Lincoln forward in the narrative we've
also given the city its own diverse
criminal ecology which play a huge role
in Lincoln's quest to tear down the mob
[Music]
let's take a look at just a few of the
very districts in new Bordeaux and what
lurks beneath the surface and in the
back alleys of the city a reimagined
version of New Orleans is made up of ten
districts each with its own distinct
flavor we have the scenic a mysterious
Bayou which is right for exploration
[Music]
but is also where the Italian mob and
their allies run guns and produce
moonship
to the west of the city is vibrant
Delray Hall which is home to Lincoln and
a surrogate family before they are
betrayed by the Italian law
[Music]
[Applause]
eventually the hollow is taken over by
the Dixie mob who kick up to the
Italians and use the neighborhood as the
base of operations for heroin and sex
rooms
so the north of the city is majestic
Frisco fields with its manicured lawns
and mansions this is also where the
marcano family has partnered with the
racist Southern Union and cooks PCP at
the local University
[Music]
and in the center of the city is
bustling downtown or historic buildings
and plazas sits side-by-side with
gleaming skyscrapers
[Music]
but this is also where the mom's
bookkeeper Tony Durazo blackmails local
politicians and scams the city through
sham construction sites how did you
manage to get to Tony de Rossi oh I had
bugs and wiretaps all over the damn
place when that weirdo left the Royal
Hotel to deal with one of his men I was
listening
[Music]
donut I didn't know you was coming I'm
just backing away your ladyship how long
you been running this business Jo ha ha
I know five videos 5 years 3 months and
18 days
this is turn look I know I've been
laughing in my fault
I've always placed a premium on
maintaining order if you let the rod set
in eventually it will take hold and
destroy everything you've built the only
solution is to isolate eradicated before
it takes hope understand Joe Russ Tony
you gotta listen to me some nuts out
there shooting L out everything you know
I mean in my mini kill yes
Dominic is it
you will take the armored car and
personally oversee the collection of all
outstanding monies owed to us and I
clear on this yes mr. Rizzo once you
have collected what is due deliver it
directly to me at the hotel the code to
the elevator is zero four five one from
there Lincoln had a couple of options he
could use the elevator code and going
through the lobby which meant shooting
the hell out of the place or he could
steal Dominic's car and going quiet
through the hotel's parking garage
killing tony is our focus right now is
capturing downtown will strike a major
blow against the Italian mob but before
we go after Tony will want to resupply
and we can do this by calling in our
weapons dealer once the mobile store
rise we can pick out the gear that will
best suit our play stop as with most of
the missions in mafia 3 if Tony can be
taken out in many different ways we can
go in guns blazing we can take a
stealthy approach we can even call in
reinforcements it's really all up to the
player
this is like Christmas morning was I
picked up in this mission we have two
distinct ways to get to Tony who's holed
up in the penthouse of his hotel we can
storm the lobby or steal his bag man's
car and sneak through the hotel's garage
and up to the penthouse which is the
path that will take care we're good
call me if you need me I gave him six
months at least
we some manners in or
[Music]
Bologna and Dominic park anywhere
[Music]
I was gone for a minute Tony wouldn't
man mr. Durazo and how long have you
been using huh Easton Taurasi Oh ain't
the second chance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it would be difficult not to I've
already taken the appropriate steps to
address the situation
believe me things are well in hand we
haven't lost anything of any
significance except for some men and
they can be replaced in fact they're the
easiest thing to replace I understand
completely and you have my word that all
payments will continue as scheduled none
of our business associates need to
concern themselves with our recent
difficulties
[Music]
should clear on out of here okay here's
the thing congressman when mr. terrazzo
made his very generous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and no way you get to you boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are you made a mess
[Music]
you really think you know how all this
is gonna play out don't you Julia yeah
kill me I'll be replaced tomorrow
no one will even notice you're wrong
everyone will notice
[Music]
war on the streets of our fair city is a
gunman storm the Royal Hotel killing an
untold number of men there was a loud
crash like a bomb going off I looked up
and there was a man falling from the top
of the building then all these men
showed up and every one of them had a
gun they ran into the Royal and that's
when the shooting started
I still don't know how the hell Lincoln
got out of that hotel
[Music]
you